les ouvrages qui sont passés de main en
main un dieu unique chargé d'histoire et
d'histoires de lecteurs qui ont passé
beaucoup de temps
la bibliothèque départementale fête
cette année ses cent soixante ans les
lecteurs étaient nombreux à venir dans
le patio célébrer ce moment important
avec toute l'équipe de la bd
celle ci a lâché au mot parmi les
invités le sol qui garde un souvenir
impérissable des cénotaphes et à la
bibliothèque et bratz a toujours été un
endroit magique un endroit merveilleux
endroit
où j'étais bien j'étais tranquille où
personne m'embêter
pour les dames qui était là était
adorable et très très dense et c'était
nécessaire
voilà ça pour moi la bibliothèque
départementale c'est mon enfance et mon
adolescence
c'est juste merveilleux des lecteurs
mais également des agents qui pour
certains ont passé toute leur carrière
dans la magnifique bâtisse
j'ai toujours aimé travailler avec le
public j'ai toujours aimé les dire et
c'est pour ça que j'ai jamais voulu
aller travailler dans un autre service
c'est une chance de travailler dans ce
temple de la peinture j'ai commencé ma
carrière à la bibliothèque centrale de
prêt qui ou en bouger beaucoup
parle d'un bibliobus et sujet eu
l'occasion d'aller à mafate en même un
hélicoptère et apporter des vivres là
bas quand je suis arrivé la bibliothèque
davantage je me disais est ce que je
vais m'adapter à ce nouveau rythme c'est
à dire statique rester en restant sur
place et j'ai découvert
le fonds régional et
qui m'a tout de suite transporté fait
voyager
dedans non seulement de l'espace et du
temps étant également l'amour de la
lecture c'est d'ailleurs le maître mot
est la devise retenue pour cet
anniversaire
1855 2015 cent soixante ans d'amour du
livre j&j a travaillé trente quatre ans
parce que 35 mais en fait je le
fréquente depuis 60 ans ainsi que quand
j'avais 10 ans quand j'avais 12 ans je
venais chez h et des pillages latin
comme on disait était un sixième au
lycée leconte de lisle a quitté et je
vais l'épopée de les traductions latines
et grecques
on les dit que ce boulevard les
placements
les lectures ont ponctué cette soirée
avec lolita monga du centre dramatique
de l'océan du prêt même si jamais les
autres aussi je vais devoir de les
accueillir de les protéger
c'est un de mes préférés je dois
l'avouer extraits de textes d'auteurs
qui ont été commandés par laurence
exceptionnellement pour cette soirée des
auteurs qui ont travaillé avec la
bibliothèque auteurs dont je fais partie
d'ailleurs et puis des des recueils de
parole
des personnels de la bibliothèque et
puis des usagers de la bibliothèque
qui ont été recueillis aussi et puis que
j'ai réécrit pour former un petit coeur
bibliothèque des notes de piano qui
s'élève dans le patio et me jeanne
cherhal qui a embelli ce moment avec
douceur notamment avec deux morceaux
inédits d'après un poème de jean lebel